[موسيقى]
إنه تقليد عمره قرون
، وليس لأصحاب القلوب الضعيفة
أنا متحمس الآن ، لا أريد أن يلمس أي شخص
العسل.
لتنمو
مع ما يصل إلى 50000 نحلة في كل
اختبار صندوق يمكن أن يستغرق عدة
ساعات ويمكن أن تكون كثيفة العمالة ، فهي
مخلوق رائع بشكل
جماعي هذه المخلوقات الصغيرة مهمة
جدًا لبقاء كوكبنا على
الاقتصادات ،
أعتقد فقط أننا  يجب
حمايتهم
انظروا أن نحل العسل ليس مجرد منتج للعسل ، فإن
ثلث
إنتاج المحاصيل الغذائية في العالم مثل اللوز
والأفوكادو يعتمد على تلقيح
الملقحات من الحشرات بشكل رئيسي
يساهم النحل بما يصل إلى 181 مليار
دولار في صناعة الأغذية الزراعية سنويًا
ولكن كله  تتعرض المستعمرات للدمار بسبب
الأمراض
واستخدام المبيدات الحشرية ومبيدات الفطريات
في الزراعة
العام الماضي في الولايات المتحدة
فقد النحالون 43 في المائة من
مستعمراتهم  الخبر السار هو أن تقنية سمارت بي
يمكن أن تأتي للإنقاذ
في أعالي جبال ويكلو على بعد حوالي
ساعة جنوب دبلن في أيرلندا
لقد كان سيمون لينش جزءًا من ساحة اختبار
لتقنية سمارت بي الجديدة الناشئة
على مدار العامين الماضيين
وهناك  هل ملكتنا
عبارة عن مستشعر صغير متصل بالإنترنت
تم وضعه تحت سقف الخلية
حيث يقيس درجة حرارة الرطوبة
والصوت والحركة
لدينا خلايا نحل هنا في أيرلندا
في المملكة المتحدة وجنوب إفريقيا في الولايات
المتحدة وما كنا نفعله  على مدار
العامين الماضيين ، تم جمع البيانات من
خلايا النحل هذه لبناء
قاعدة بيانات عملاقة لخلية النحل ، وهي شركة إيرلندية ناشئة ،
تحمي شركة apris
الادعاءات القائلة بأن المستشعرات يمكن أن تساعد في تقليل
الخسائر وتحسين صحة
نحل العسل في جميع أنحاء العالم
عن طريق تنبيه مربي النحل على الفور إذا كانت
هناك مشكلة في الخلية
تأتي كل هذه البيانات  بالعودة إلينا في
كورك في أيرلندا ،
نطبق تقنيات التعلم الآلي
الخاصة بنا وذكائنا الاصطناعي
جميعًا معًا ويتم ذلك
تلقائيًا  يتم إرسالها مرة أخرى إلى مربي النحل من
خلال
لدينا واجهة ويب ، كما نقوم أيضًا بإجراء
تنبيهات عبر الرسائل النصية والبريد الإلكتروني ،
حيث تسمح التكنولوجيا لمربي النحل مثل
سيمون بمراقبة خلايا النحل عن بُعد
حتى يتمكنوا من التحقق بشكل أسرع وأكثر
سهولة مما
إذا كانت هناك مشكلة قد
ترغب في ذلك  انظر إلى الخلية رقم ثلاثة وألق نظرة على تلك الخلية
لأنه
يبدو أن هذا الشخص لا ينمو
أكثر من غيره ، إنه نوع من التراجع في
الوقت الحالي ، لذلك سيحتاج ذلك في الواقع إلى
بعض الاهتمام ، حسنًا ، نعم ستفعل ذلك ،
ومن المأمول أن هذه التكنولوجيا سوف
السماح لمربي النحل التجاريين
بتوسيع أعمالهم لضمان المزيد من
التلقيح
والمزيد من الغذاء لعدد متزايد من سكان العالم ،
انظر أن التلقيح هو أحد
أهم العمليات البيولوجية على كوكبنا
[موسيقى]
عندما يخرج النحل بحثًا عن العلف ، يجمعون
الرحيق وحبوب اللقاح لإعادتهم إلى
مستعمرة عندما تهبط على زهرة ، يتم تغطية النحلة
بحبوب اللقاح
وهي مادة شبيهة بالغبار تنتجها
الزهرة تحتوي على
المواد التناسلية الذكرية
بينما تنتقل النحلة من زهرة إلى زهرة
، يسقط حبوب اللقاح ،
آمل أن يزيل الغبار عن الهيكل التناسلي الأنثوي
الذي يخصب
الأعضاء التناسلية للنبات ، ويبدأ إنتاج
البذور
والنباتات الجديدة ، وأعتقد أن هذا
سيعطيني إمكانية زيادة المقبلات
وإنتاج المزيد من العسل
ومن ناحيتي ، فإن مساعدة البيئة أكثر
من حيث التلقيح بشكل
أساسي سيكونون قادرين على
الاحتفاظ بالعديد من خلايا النحل لنفس العدد
من العمال بنفس المبلغ الذي
ينفقونه على أشياء مثل
الأعلاف والعلاجات وسيكونون كذلك
قد تكون قادرة على زيادة
كمية التلقيح ومخرجات العسل
التي حصلوا عليها في عملياتهم بشكل كبير ،
قد تكون تقليدًا تاريخيًا
ولكن التكنولوجيا الذكية
تأمل في ضمان مستقبل مثمر لها